Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Oxygen Not Included.
Now, I am NOT going to let my people die.
I'm going to grow very attached to them
and I'm gonna be very attentive to their needs.
Now, in the last one, I did not realize that
oxygen did not spread completely through
the open area that you were.
So, that was my problem.
I didn't think that would happen.
They all suffocated to death
and that's... very bad.
So, I've got Gus, Mystique, and Sybil here.
Who, supposedly... *reads character box*
This Gus just wants everyone to be happy.
Mystique's defy all labels.
Sybil's always get what they want even when they shouldn't.
So, there's like some weird dynamic here
where these are quote/unquote "duplicates."
So, I think what these are - these are "copies" of people.
Like, the portal thing that they came through
They have a "template" person.
So, when it says *this* Gus just wants everyone to be happy
Gus is a type of duplicant that they have
and you can always expect them to
be similar. So, when you shuffle through them...
Yvette, Sadie, Sadie... and then they each
have different attributes. But it - it's really interesting.
Woah, level nine runner.
Holy shit. Level 8 miner. I'll take this.
This looks good. Gus, Josie, Lenny you guys
are going to be my babboos. And I'm going to
get with the Incredible Fortress. The Not- So-Cute-Cantaloupe. The Not So Duplicate
Beyond the un- the uncomfortable space prison!
Yeah that seems about right. Well, at least in this prison you won't die...
maybe. Oh good, water is actually closer
by. Ok so.. it would be best to start
digging. I know, I know, I got it.
So what we're going to do is we're going
to do our best here. We're going to just dig this out.
We're gonna... whatever the hell these are..
We're gonna dig theeese. We're gonna- just gonna
keep diggin. Gonna dig a whole bunch
and everything's gonna be good.
So I'm assuming that the glowy blueness
in the background there, that is oxygen.
Oh it is oxygen! You can just go over and that's what it is.
So...
As they keep digging, I'm revealing
more of the oxalite that's gonna be
able to provide all the oxygen that I
need in the beginning. So in this one I'm gonna try to
establish a better base because,
if there's one thing that I didn't do,
it's establish a very good base so- and also
intelligently dig towards the things
where oxygen is already provided, like
over here there's already a- oh my god what is that...
oh I did not know that there were going
to be other creatures in this game that
is news to me okay so that's interesting
there are definitely new creatures here to
explore
that's fascinating
so I'm gonna leave this narrow because I just
want to come over here so I can have
oxygen there and there is oxygen down
there to so that water has been oxygenated
in some way I'm going to loop back
around and eventually come down to that one I'm just gonna try and to do it in a way
that doesn't make everyone die okay i
think i can go down on one like one
platform they can walk through there at
least that will be the test so if they
can try to dig out this piece of dirt
there dig that one
no he cannot oh ok so thats- that is a
limiting factor so they cannot go down
across single platform things but the
can cross here I think
no they cannot oh yeah they can the lazy
sack of crap what are you doing over there
you make me look bad right then
so either way we need to dig slow enough
that oxygen can spread everywhere that
it needs to go and in addition to that
it can do everything else it needs to do I'm going to
cancel that one don't dig that one ok so
we gotta get down to that water but we
can't just drop down that would be
stupid
hey you got a muck root good job Josie
Josie you're doing us all proud i love
Josie Josie's awesome Josie's just so good
it's so good-a what you do alright i'm gonna
build an outhouse because we definitely
need that
all right outhouse by here by the stinker
room! Alright, so we need to get down to that
water that is paramount
Josie's going over there oh so they each pick
their- oh each one is assigned to a different
person
ok all right- ok i think that- that's not
bad
so by twos they can yeah they can climb
up and climb out of that there is oxygen
down there if they go down there then
suddenly they have access to water
correct yes
do they need to actually touch it to be
accessible oh that looks funky that
water is behaving some bizarre properties
that I dont- that I don't appreciate all right then
it's very sticky water. It's gross. all right then
but this is fine
because now
we have at least some
oxygenated area and then we're doing
better on supplies so we're going to
keep digging out here this is just dirt
that's good cultivatable soil i like
the sound of that I like the sound of that so we need to build hmm so what
should we do we need we need a lot of
more resources here so this is where a
lot of metal is so I'm gonna have
them dig up to there because i just
want to get the right places to dig to
and then that should do it right that will be it
alright go for it guys go for it RUUN so they're doing their thing
they're gonna dig they're gonna dig they're gonna
dig they're gonna dig dig dig dig dig dig
dig dig dig dig come on guys hurry up
you got a lot of work to do don't be oh
they don't have oxygen up there okay so
they're little bit of- they're just a
little bit of running out of oxygen
which is not good
you don't have to you don't have to kill
yourself guys you don't have to do that
you can go back down you can go back
down at any time now
I know, go for it, breathe! Jeez... right
you're fine you're fine just hold your breath
You're good, you're all good okay. oxygen will eventually
flow up there I think unless it just
won't flow that far
so what they could do is they could
build- oh man, that is just that is literally
just- ah, there it goes, there it goes ok so that's
really cool, there's like a fluid dynamics
to the oxygen around here in a lot of
gases so they all they all want to
occupy the space that they're in so all
right so now that we got that we got
some ore there we can actually start
making some stuff we can make...
the power generator well I guess it's time to- Josie, DO NOT
die up there Josie I swear to god Josie
why did you pass out right then and
there
these duplicates do not behave correctly
right I think it's okay i think Josie's gonna
be okay this is a little scary you know
you scare me. Not accessible...not acceptable. Aww, they're such
sweet little babbies.
oh I want you to not die
I just don't want you to die I think you
shouldn't die is that noble of me to say
is that responsible and mature of me to
say i don't want you guys to die
it's true I don't! I believe in you. I believe in all of you.
I'm gonna dig this out a little more so
we have access to go over here
what is that? Abyssalite?! I dunno what that means...
Obsidian... Cool, I guess?
good stuff maybe i don't know i'm hoping
that more oxygen is going to be able to
go through there okay then you guys do
your thing suck your food out of the
jail the box
Go on, go on, suck that food out you got it you're
doing great guys. C'mon, hurry up. C'mon, chop to it!
Now now now now, go go go go! We got stuff to do we
got stuff to do come on! Aw, don't use the out
house now come on get it get it get it
get it go get get get get get you go go
I didn't plan that out very well but you
guys hurry up let's do your thing! Ooo, more
oxygen is flowing through, that's good. Okay, good good good good good. Okay.
*Mark scatting?*
Good good good good good gooood. Okay.
So they're going to do their thing and they're
going to keep digging the only problem is
oxygen is just a little bit spares over
there that's fine because what i can do
is i can make an oxygen generator over
there
because there's oxygen right here so put
that there, put that there put that there, put that
there and then oxygen production with
that they're right there and then that
should be it always requires a top okay
put it there but they're right there
good good the grid always running on
oxygen
come on hurry up we gotta get oxygen in
here please please hurry up there we go
haha look bad
oh ya SE okay buddy alright that battery
is full and that's going to produce
oxygen we're good we're doing a lot
better than we were
I mean we're not doing great but we're
doing better than we were ok so oxygen
is filling up that area then we're going
to be able to mine out all this stuff
like I think we can do a four-block just
get that stuff dig a man i'm going to
look into more interesting things to do
here like the food processor electrical
wiring for the fair speeded-up go far
and fake bois-guilbert gasps got who
Thank You Josie and I would have one of
those in my house we want who renewable
energy just threw up like like if I had
to power my computer with a flight I
would be in such good shape because I
never be honest you know what I don't
know if they're going to be able to fill
if they're going to be able to go get
water from the water place because I
might need to dig that out a bit better
i don't know though maybe
oh wait yes your beautiful ball your
beautiful ball it's true
oh you're not beautiful talked to
consuming contaminated oxygen
oh is that what the slime produces slime
produces contaminated oxygen
is that good tho that a good thing
should I trust you i don't know if I
trust you but I'm gonna come talk to you
in a bit after i build my shift doing
feeling ok so it doesn't have I don't
have meal life which is the problem i
don't know where the hell did you get
that we've got something you grow
there's something that I could grow a
case for memorial all that's that ok
alright then let's be should feel bad i
should build bed from my plea proof look
at that I have bed and then an eventual
bed for someone else who ever wants to
join of art show
Lucy don't type of the cycle anyway
you're going to need bed don't just pass
out in the middle of nowhere go to a
goddamn bed
yeah there you go good job Lenny you're
doing great Lani got you doing great too
always hopeful that someone going to be
there so now the question is are they
going to go they actually aren't just going
to pass out with where they stand-
I BUILT THOSE BEDS JUST IN TIME
OH, LOOK AT EM
THEYRE SO CUTE I love you guys I love you
guys
okay so it looks like we're going to
need eventually to build a research
station that's what i'm going to do next
this
the wiring up to this one connect the
dots here we go
and then in the next morning we'll build
those things will be able to research
new technologies we've got a new
duplicate on the way very soon looking
up for us
things are going better than I thought
they were now that not everyone is DEAD!
I didn't know about the oxygen thing
okay i didn't know about that and
hopefully everything will be okay that's
weird because what that means is that
non-stop always going to bring new
people in no matter what there's always
going to be new people coming through
that printing pod
I can't exactly stop that and maybe even
it's going to accelerate which is going
to be really stressful because you
always have to make sure that you have
more and more people like at the ready
Ohhh, COOL!
RESEARCH?! :D
HELL YEAH! >:D
Percolation sanitation pressure
management
ok farming tech seems like the most
logical to do so we're going to have
that... This uncomfortable space prison
is going to be the top of research no
fabrication cued - What does that mean i don't
know what that fabricate i don't okay
novice research fabricate that do that
up fabricated away
why do you need dirt for them done
we got mine real hard for that one
right then
oh, GUS IS DOING IT! GO, GUS, GO!
okay so we need 20 research points to be
able to research that in the whole
research tree so farming tech is getting
it first so if you had multiple ones of
those you could do a lot of shit but it
takes a lot of power apparently so I
just need to constantly make sure that
that has all the fabrication it needs to
be able to conduct enough research and
then we'll be able to make food which is
going to be very important because we
don't have all the food in the world but
we got enough food to last us a while
the next duplicated the next baby's
gonna be ready in no time
J-Josie? x3
Oh, she's a narcoleptic
that's going to be bad if you fall
asleep in a place where you don't have
OHHH do not go in there ono
chlorine will kill you in an instant
HOOBOY
Habababa...
okay don't do that well that's a lot of
chlorine that is a lot
ok so we've got a lot of really
interesting materials over here but I
don't know if they're going to be what
we need
also I don't know how to build properly
to go up to where we need to go
hello hi hello who got hello
you didn't to duplicate oh look at you
guys
hello matches are painfully gullible and
other duplicants like to take advantage
of it every chance they get home can't
get this duplicate just can't operate a
big tool for the life of them bottomless
stomach
oh man
no one ever asked for Pam's bad opinions
but she's always happy to offer them
anyway
well I don't want people that just can't
dig that kinda sucks but I guess he's
got good construction so he specialized
as a builder and not as a digger which I
suppose is ok I like max-access cool
printim print them up fool
imax welcome max are you still cute
max what are you going to do with your
life what are you gonna do
insufficient oxygen generation oh ok so
we need more oxygen generation that's
understood so we just need to make
another makes another oxygen generator
that all we need to do I hope that's
what we need to do pay attention to that
ok so hopefully max the Builder oh no
Leni alright then
max you know you just you just play
around oh yes camp the adorable camp you
do which got to make you do what you
gotta do
ok hopefully that's gonna be enough to
be able to offset the oxygen generation
crucial
hey I'm even microbes we gotta have more
research come on racer cowgirl crap
I'll continuously fabricate that's what
I need to do ok now we have continuously
fabricate that Phil if resources
available ok so that's going to be
constantly going max you're doing if you
are you smart guy
are you still smart i like that good job
max okay so things are looking in pretty
good shape like oddly enough things are
surviving well here so i think is a good
stopping point with this episode and
then in the next one we're going to
carry on and make sure that they advance
their life just a little bit fun
so thank you everybody so much for
watching hope you enjoy the adventure
discussed max any ability will be
supplies and ammunition
probably not fit with me in charging in
the uncomfortable favors and probably
not so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always about you in the
So, that was my problem. I didn't think that would happen,